bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
pour une autre édition d' espace
autochtone en direct aujourd'hui un
sujet très d'actualité en fait il a fait
l'actualité
la semaine dernière le mois dernier
l'année dernière les dix dernières
années et plus on va parler du respect
des droits des communautés autochtones
sur leur territoire lorsqu'il est
question de ressources naturelles alors
on parle évidemment case odieux que
pipeline toutes les ressources
naturelles avec un avocat
nadir andré nadir andré est avocat chez
borden ladner gervais bonjour monsieur
andré bonjour vous êtes le chef national
de ce groupe
effectivement là on est environ une
trentaine d'avocats wii est un jeu
dirige le groupe droit autochtone quel
est votre spécialité à l'intérieur de ce
bureau en tant que chef national et en
tant qu'avocat on a plusieurs
spécialités mais disons que tout ce qui
est relié aux droits territoriaux
ressources naturelles et autonomie
gouvernementale cc montchamp protectrice
pas ils vont ratisser large
vous êtes sur l'ensemble du canada on
offre nos juridictions sont nombreuses
notre équipe est nombreuse on qu'on est
capable de faire d'effectuer toutes nos
services a dans l'ensemble du pays
alors vous allez pouvoir vous aider à y
comprendre dans un dossier qui est
extrêmement touffus également mon
collègue guy bois chef de pupitre
journalistes à espace auto tonnes dont
jour dit aux jo alors vous aussi vous en
connaissez à une bonne partie là de ces
dossiers là bon parce que vous avez
travaillé entre autres à sept-îles vous
avez eu à traiter ces questions
j'ai même connu le grand-père de nadir
de territoire mais qui est-elle de
négociateur pour la nation innu du de la
convention de la baie james
les inouk ont d'ailleurs refusé de
signer cette convention
oui effectivement parce que quand on
s'intéresse
aux enjeux autochtones nécessairement le
concept de télé 3 s'impose par jimmy
wales a que si vous regardez
pourquoi on en parle et si on parle de
la crise cannes et sète cannes et
s'attaquer la crise d'oka si on parle
des crises autour de transmontagne ou du
gazoduc dans les noms at on vu une
tannée tout ça a à voir avec le
territoire et lie aux ressources du
territoire est autre chose aussi qui a à
voir avec le territoire c'est fou la
question de l'autonomie gouvernementale
alors on se dit d'aloyse sur les aider
est une loi raciste
là dessus les gouvernements s'entendent
et les autochtones sans entente sauf
qu'on ne sait pas comment la changer et
puis tout à coup et a perdu cette notion
d'autonomie gouvernement alors
l'autonomie gouvernementale sans les
ressources ils sont les assises
territoriales
ça devient une coquille vide oui alors
vous voyez on est vraiment au coeur des
enjeux autochtones quand on porte ce
thème et rendrait vous êtes d'accord
tout à fait
ellis queen aussi qui est là aujourd'hui
comme chaque semaine d'ailleurs pour
parler d'un enjeu alors on va aussi
parler de ressources naturelles on va
s'intéresser à un territoire qui collait
à celui des états unis et on part dans
le grand nord ouest du canada
autant on va parler de forage oui et
puis aussi on parle beaucoup de
difficultés que les premiers nationale
pour faire reconnaître leurs droits ici
au canada
oui mais quand on parle de l'arctique et
le west lactique
il est tout le faire d'un noir qui est
la région de refuge faunique de l'axé
qu'en alaska et là c'est projet
américain mais qu'à voir les impacts sur
les premiers nationaux canadiens sont
ces enjeux qui a les impacts
transnationaux oui alors ça complique
les choses
vous allez pouvoir participer à cette
discussion lorsque je pense que c'est un
dossier que vous connaissez aussi n'est
ce pas optimum alors avant mais en fait
pour mettre la table parlons de ce que
dit la déclaration des nations unies sur
les droits des peuples autochtones
concernant justement le respect du
territoire
bah c'est justement ce matin je me suis
dit je vais relire sans boire un peu
qu'est ce que nous dit la déclaration
m et je le suis aperçu que ce sont les
articles les plus les plus importants et
on le retrouve même dans le préambule je
vous cite au coeur la déclaration des
nations unies sur les droits des peuples
autochtones les états signataires
reconnaissent le contrôle par les
peuples autochtones de leurs terres de
leurs territoires et de leurs ressources
aussi comme base de leur développement
selon leurs priorités alors vous rendez
compte
mettez ça en perspective maintenant face
au dos i-trans monteyne faso ou dossiers
par exemple de l'ént caustique
donc on sait où il ya des revendications
il nous a donné des gens de mega contre
autres alors on reprenne éthique joué
exactement donc on est vraiment au coeur
des revendications politiques
il faut bien voir aussi que en amont il
faut que le colonialisme lui même est
caractérisée par une appropriation des
terres alors on est là au coeur du débat
peut-être pour par rapport à ses
déclarations il ya trois choses utiles à
savoir à ce stade si c'est que oui le
canada en ratifier l'entente dix ans
après son adoption par la plupart des
autres états par contre au canada tout
traité international pour avoir une
portée juridique doit faire l'objet
d'une loi de mise en oeuvre et cette
fois là n'a toujours pas été adoptée
elle a été présentée par le député roméo
saganash l'année dernière elle est
encore à l'étude et pau taille qu'elle
sera pas adoptée cette année compte tenu
notamment d'élections fédérales général
alon on verra fait ça c'est une chose
et même si elle est adoptée par le
canada l'autre enjeu c'est que l'état
les ressources naturelles sauf exception
louis sont de juridiction provinciale
article 92
hors la loi fonctionnel 267 et
l'arctique sang neuf donc l'étape les
propriétés sont propriétés des provinces
et donc dans un état fédéral mais
mais si le canada s'engage à
l'international yodé cros fédéral qui
font en sorte que les provinces ont un
mot à dire également lorsque le canada
s'engage alors même s'il y avait une loi
fédérale qui est adoptée sur la
déclaration des peuples autochtones
il faudrait que les provinces s'engagent
également il donc l'aspect fédéral
l'aspect province à la troisième chose
qu'il faut tenir compte c'est que les
droits autochtones sont protégés depuis
le 17 avril 1982 avec l'article 35 oui
et donc on a des jeunes juristes
on a déjà une jurisprudence abondante
sur la portée des droits territoriaux et
des ressources naturelles au canada même
c'est incomplet
donc il va falloir s'assurer que les
dispositions de la déclaration viennent
pas porté atteinte à ses droits déjà
reconnu dans la conscience parce que il
faut dire que à l'échelle du pays à
l'échelle planétaire
il n'y a pas d'autres états qui
reconnaissent les droits autochtones
dans leur constitution
alors faudra faire attention que là ce
que sur les objectifs de la déclaration
viennent pas porter atteinte aux droits
des genres colin et peuples autochtones
au canada fait une complexité oui nous
avons dans les prochaines années comment
cette loi va être mise en oeuvre dans
quel contexte
selon quel encadrement actuellement au
canada quels sont les autochtones qui
dont on respecte le plus les droits dans
quelle partie du pays
ben c'est un peu difficile à dire parce
que premièrement il ya il ya trois
catégories on peut dire un haut niveau
je le disais que
des peuples autochtones il ya d'abord
les peuples autochtones qui ont des
traités historiques donc les traités de
numéroter commencé avec robinson dur en
avoir la confédération jusqu'en 1935
avec le le traité numéro 9 de deuxième
partie le traité de la baie james
donc dans cette catégorie là il ya une
formule juridique ou à ce que le titre
autochtone a été cédée en échange de
droits issus de traités fait pour la
portion donc qu'ils aient touche environ
de l'ontario jusqu'au rocheuses c'est
des traités qui on voit ce que les
terres ont été cédés au courant et
maintenant fonds ont un statut
particulier parce que les couronnes
détiennent la pleine propriété plus sur
le titre sauf exception la deuxième
catégorie c'est lé traité moderne ou
est-ce que depuis la convention la baie
james il ya vingt-six traité moderne au
canada est maintenant 27 jeux parce
qu'on a eu un autre était conclue en
colombie-britannique dernièrement et
donc dans ces traités là où est-ce qu'on
renonce sont plus à la formule de la
cession des droits on vient chercher
d'autres formules ou à ce que les droits
ancestraux continue d'exister mais sont
encadrés par le traité modem puis pour
vous donner une idée un traité moderne à
environ en moyenne 500 pages retraités
historique en avait quatre ou cinq
xavier la distinction à ce qu'on rentre
vraiment dans tous les détails et des
ressources naturelles de l'autonomie
gouvernementale de comment ce qu'on ait
consulté et que c'était vrai et c est
finalement il ya ceux qui ont peur de
traiter donc qui ont des revendications
territoriales et qui vise à faire
reconnaître leurs titres ancestral sur
le territoire les ressources naturelles
et cela bon soin qu'ils sont devant les
tribunaux pour faire reconnaître l'otite
ou soit qu'ils sont en négociation pour
avoir
éventuellement un traitement dans donc
là les revendications sa catégorie soit
devant ceux qui préfèrent le tribunal et
où ceux qui préfèrent les négocié ou
ceux qui ont les moyens d'aller devant
les tribunaux aussi parce que voilà le
problème parce que l'article 35 de la
constitution c'est tout petit alors il
se construit finalement au fur et à
mesure que que les jurisprudences ont
publié or pour des dations comme les
attikameks par exemple qui ont des
revendications historiques
elle se retrouve en course mais ça coûte
une fortune bas juste pour vous donner
un ordre d'idée la dernière née à la
dernière est la seule nation qui a
réussi à prouver son titre la nation
ticotin rencontre des britanniques
le recours jusqu'à la cour suprême a
coûté en tout 31 millions de dollars
dont dont 11 millions que les courants
ont dû payer
oui et 19 millions payés par les
premières mentions comme donc vous voyez
que là la preuve qui est aveugle c'est
là toute la sauce problème quand on
parle aux autochtones ils disent bien
pourquoi je dois prouver mes droits sur
mon téléphone j'ai tellement premier ça
serait au canada prouver qu'ils ont des
droits comme en développement la
philosophie il aimait la cour suprême
depuis les airs et quart d'heure et
delgado en camps de roms 1973 des liens
manquants 97 et le dit la première
masson qui prétend voir en titre doit le
prouver et c'est là toute la difficulté
parce que il faut à ce moment alors
prouver une occupation exclusive et
continue entre la date de souveraineté
de la couronne est aujourd'hui et la
date de souveraineté mais elle varie à
travers le canada rencontrent les
britanniques seniors autour de 1832 mais
au québec c'est aux alentours de 1760
lorsque les britanniques leçon on
renverser le régime france alors
approuvées en titre d'aujourd'hui à 10
760 non seulement est très complexe mais
extrêmement dispendieux et c'est la
raison pour laquelle plus en ass
autochtone ne voit pas la solution des
tribunaux comme étant
réalisable à cause des coûts est-ce
qu'il faut parler un petit peu de la
différence entre la situation dans les
provinces et les territoires
ben au niveau des provinces et des
territoires au niveau du titre c'est
tout la même chose
il n'y a pas de y'a pas de distinction
entre les provinces parce que bon on
sait que les terres sont supposés da des
terres réservées aux indiens donc de
compétence fédérale
c'est la dispostion 91,24 dans la loi
constitutionnelle donc le régime foncier
autochtone est la même à travers le pays
au pod les pas de distinction est la
seule distinction qui pourrait avoir par
exemple dans les territoires et dans le
grand mans c'est que puis en corse une
théorie c'est que les ce qu'on appelait
les terres de rupert qui ont été donnée
en concession en 1577 870 à la compagnie
de la baie du son ont été redonnés en
guillemets à la couronne britannique qui
l'a redonné au canada et donc la dalle
de souveraineté selon plusieurs experts
se trouverait 1970 dont la date de
souveraineté pour ceux qui revendiquent
des territoires dans les enquêteurs ne
veulent pas serait beaucoup plus rester
qu'ailleurs au pays donc c'est attendre
la date de souveraineté il n'y a pas de
distinction au niveau de la
reconnaissance des droits
moi je rennes question jeu
je veux dire un peu comme les latino
américains qui nous permette d'atterrir
dans des choses bien conquête je suis
président d'une entreprise mais j'ai au
lac ont trouvé une mine sur un
territoire reconnu par exemple d in ou
alors est-ce que je peux demain débarqué
avec mon équipement et commencer à
foirer si j'ai obtenu des permis par
exemple du canada ou du québec
ben vous dirais que jusqu'à récemment la
réponse était oui je
jusqu'à temps que tout d'abord la cour
suprême en 2004 avec les arrêts idate à
coureurs viennent dire et un an plus
tard pour en ce qui a trait aux terres
de traiter avec mes guizhou la cour
suprême est venu dire regardez les
nations qui revendiquent des droits soit
parce qu'ils sont dans les tribunaux ou
en revendications territoriales
ben il donne l'information sur leurs
terres et 10 est au courant voici
monsieur je pense est mon territoire la
couronne s'engage à négocier et la cour
ne dira vous pouvez pas pas mal les
trente quarante cinquante ans que prend
cette négociation la continuer à
exploiter comme si de rien n'était alors
que s'il est possible que ces nations
autochtones à ercis
et si elles ont un titre leur
consentement est requis avant vous
puissiez développer alors d'où là la
reconnaissance que une obligation
concessionnel de de consulter et aux
besoins d'accommoder ses droits et la
cour suprême est allé à une étape encore
plus
plus élevé avec la constitution c'est
que la cour supérieure à 10 toutes les
nations autochtones qui revendique un
titre donc pas si un traité conforme à
100 leurs droits tout projet qui serait
allé sur leur territoire sans qu'ils
donnent leur consentement
c'est à vos risques et périls parce que
si vous obtenez pas leur consentant peu
à la même s'ils n'ont pas encore prouvé
leur titre le jour qui vont le faire
oui ils pourront demander à ce que le
projet soit annulé peu importe à quel
état le projet rendu et là ça peut être
des barrages hydroélectriques ça peut
être des mêmes ça peut être des parcs
line ça peut être n'importe quoi alors
la seule chose qui peut faire en sorte
que le consentement ne soit pas requis
c'est de la manière dont les courants
donc ce être déchargés de leur
obligation de consulter pendant le
projet plus qui vont consulter plus que
la couronne à ce moment leur vote est
justifié de dire bon j'ai pas obtenu
leur consentement
mais j'étais tellement consulter que je
suis justifier d'avoir autorisé le
projet c'est donc la seule chose qui
frappe c'est une exception à vos
consentement qui est donné évidemment
ceci la première nation capable de
prouver sont conception c'est qu'il ya
un aspect juridique important vous venez
d'élaborer ce sera souvent dans les
différentes cours mais on oublie très
souvent qu'il ya aussi l'aspect
politique parce que c'est une chose
respecter la loi mais aujourd'hui on
sait très bien qu'une compagnie qui
arrive sans consulter et je pense que la
cour suprême aussi a défini que la
consultation c'est plus que avoir ton
avis et entamer un dialogue
1 c'est un peu ce qu'elle disait la cour
suprême alors y as tout cet aspect
politique l'a alors comment on fait pour
garder l'équilibré
quand on a un pied dans le jeu des
clapiers dans le politique ben ça
s'appelle janvier et s'approche comment
l'équilibré entre ce que des premières
nations vont prendre une position
politique par rapport au projet c'est à
dire qu'il y en a qui vont même pas
devant les tribunaux ils vont dire bon
ben je bloque l'accès au projet je fais
des barricades j'amène les gens
directement sur leur territoire pour
dire aux promoteurs et à la
place en général qu'on n'est pas
d'accord entre le projet sabin je me
prononcerai pas savoir c'est quoi la
légitimité de telles choses parce que yo
des lois dont le code criminel dont
certaines lois qui empêchent de bloquer
des chemins ou de prendre la propriété
d'autrui etc
donc je peux pas vraiment mettez dans la
mesure où un convoi voit ce que les gens
se trouvent sur leur territoire mais qui
est le propriétaire de quoi la décision
de cour suprême dans la sphère
judiciaire de kluivert en 2017 ce
apporter beaucoup sur la consultation ou
le manque de vraie consultation est ce
que ça va changer les choses ou ça
changer les choses qui a fallu ça n'a
pas changé les choses
on pourrait dire que 30 ce matin la
décision de la cour d'appel fédérale sur
le projet de changement lui est venu
amener un élément nouveau c'est à dire
l'aspect du du dialogue
et là il sera il rajoute le terme tout
et ivox qui s'en va être un peu spécial
parce que designer d'exposer d'être à
deux ou à plusieurs mètres la cour a
ajouté cette nation l'a donc la nation
était de 10 vous pouvez pas être
quelques fonctionnaires autour d'une
table à prendre des notes et à écouter
les préoccupations des autochtones puis
de rien dire puis abandonnée a d'abord
gardé on a pris note de votre passion on
va aller voir nos patrons qu'on vous
revient et l'abeille bourbon les patrons
plus patrons disent rien club et revient
des balises pour seulement
c'est ce que la cour dise c'est plus de
la consultation
il faut donc puisque est nouveau dans
franchement c'est que là l'accord est
venu dire à la table lorsque vient le
moment de parler de l'accommodement
parce que c'est la consultation tu peux
en faire ce pas enfin si a pas de
commande mas et l'ocs est un problème
qui on dirait que les cours ne sont pas
encore habitués à la notion de
l'accommodement mais ça s'apprend et
donc il faut que cela convient à dire
c'est qu'il faut que la personne soit la
table un moment donné soit en lien avec
le décideur est la confiance du ministre
ou du cabinet qui doit prendre la
décision et puisse changer la décision
besoin et ça c'est un élément majeur
parce que ça vient dire à la fonction
publique à l'exécutif qui fait la
consultation
vous pouvez pas envoyer vos petits
représentants régionaux simplement que
dit la pression s'est déchargée de notre
obligation il faut à un moment donné que
peut-être pas pendant tout le processus
parce que y'a processus qui est très
technique là il ya des échanges
scientifiques traditionnelles voire une
information on s'entend que le
sous-ministre pas besoin d'être là mais
un moment donné il ya quelqu'un qui doit
être là pour vous regarder je suis la
personne en charge dites moi c'est quoi
que vous voulez et je vais aller voir en
moi auprès du décideur que fonds peut
faire pour vous accommoder c'est ça qui
peut faire vraiment la différence c'est
ça qui avait pas opérable ça c'est pas
de faire du théâtre de consultation
c'est encore une fois l'objectif étant
d'aller chercher le consentement parce
que l'accommodement ce que de ce qui est
extraordinaire c'est que les nations
certaines voix si nous comptions pour
avoir notre consentement alors c'est
intéressant parce que c'est pas un droit
de veto si on refuse toujours d'un
projet sauf dans quelques catégories on
a vu que justement au niveau des
pipelines c'est très difficile on a vu
au niveau de l'énergie nucléaire c'est
très difficile avec un exemple au québec
deux exemples au québec d'ailleurs au
fait des dernières années dans le
nucléaire mais à part ça danse qui est
énergie men et foresterie audio vraiment
un moyen de s'entendre et à son on peut
même rajouter ce que le privé va faire
dans ce processus là c'est à dire
d'offrir des avantages socioéconomiques
pour que les nations autochtones
puissent bénéficier des retombées
puis on appelle communément les ententes
sur les interactions et avantages on
parle de redevances d'emploi pour les
autochtones de forme informations d'un
contrôle de plus en plus les contrô lée
ce qu'on appelle les procurent mcl
wasquehal l'ena sont ceux qui rient des
des entreprises importantes sont
capables à soumissionner dans les grands
projets d'infrastructure frôlé zino avec
ton post crise
on les dit nous ce que font les crises
que font plus en mation à travers le
pays de plus en plus viennent même
soumissionner compense même au maroc de
garoua gay avec
le pont mercier doit être des exemples
où est ce que il ya un moyen en échange
de l'acceptation de faire bénéficier au
maximum les nations autochtones parce
que c'est fondamentalement le problème
c'est que non seulement on appris le
territoire au fil des ans mais en plus
le fameux si je peux utiliser l'analogie
du train du développement lié partis
sans les autochtones et loeb un les
autochtones ont été mis de côté en
lecteur du développement et je pense
qu'il ya un exercice nécessaire
d'arrêter ce train là de faire entrer
autochtone d'appui de voir comment ce
qui doit être confortable dans ce train
lopy de repartir avec
parce que sinon on va se retrouver
constamment avec de plus en plus de
poissons parce que le territoire à petit
les populations augmentent incluant les
populations qu'il ya quelque chose la
prochaine étape alors on en parlait un
peu c'est la question de l'autonomie
gouvernementale dernièrement les deux
ministres responsables des autochtones
ont donné une entrevue au devoir on
disait l'année 2019 c'est l'année de
l'autonomie gouvernementale mais je me
souviens d'une réunion des premiers
ministres avec le premier ministre
trudeau où tout à coup on a évoqué la
question des gouvernements autochtones
et là tout à coup monsieur couillard
l'apparition d'un 3e ordres de
gouvernement et ça ça veut dire du point
de vue juridique réouvrir la
constitution est-ce qu'on est pas un peu
dans l'utopie quand on parle de
gouvernements autochtones c'est une
question intéressante
regardez si on fait un peu un recul
historique et on regarde une comparaison
entre les états unis et le canada
sa mère façon de comprendre aux états
unis il y a des 823 une trilogie de la
cour suprême du canada qu'on avait que
du juge michon qui est dans trois arrêts
rendus à quelques années d'intervalle au
défini que les nations autochtones
américaines étaient des nations
indépendantes en fait dépendantes
souveraine interne c'est à dire que l
était souveraine à l'intérieur des états
unis c'est à dire qu'elles pouvaient pas
faire de relations avec d'autres et or
ont monté une armée ou des choses
consommer à portsall
l'intérieur des états unis l état
souverain donc ce que ça donnait lieu
c'est que chaque équivalent d'un conseil
de bande aux états unis au sa propre
constitution dit que les souveraines
accepte d'accepter les règles
américaines au niveau des lois puisque
de l'encadrement juridique mais après ça
on gouvernement avec un palier les
fnatic fait des lois un exécutif et un
judiciaire il ya même des tribunaux dont
dans chaque communauté autochtone aux
états unis qui est après tes fonds
appelé ton tu donnes et a finalement
exactement un état à l'intérieur de
l'état et c'est intéressant parce que
ils sont elles sont en grande partie
immunisés des lois de chaque état et ne
répondent qu'aux lois fédérales
un peu comme au canada mais la moins
grande instance
au canada on a fait une loi sur les
indiens comme aux états unis mais on a
omis de mettre quelques références que
ce soit l'autonomie gouvernementale
de sorte que on en fait un cadre
juridique quoi ce qu'il y avait un
conseil de vente qui étaient nommés ou
élus des parements des époques et on a
voulu uniformiser la gouvernance à
travers le pays ce qui a plus ou moins
bien fonctionné puis c'est là que
plusieurs on entend parler aux nouvelles
de chef héréditaire de gouvernement
parallèle et tout ça et lobait ça fait
un peu sorcier tout le monde anglo mais
qu'est ce qu'il pense et ce que les
conseils de bande représente vraiment la
gouvernance locale des communautés où
est-ce que yo autre chose non je dois
vous dire puis mon opinion là dessus et
pas dans politique est plus d'ordre
juridique à l'effet que si on se réfère
encore aux territoires qui détient
territoire lacoste loi nous dit que le
titre est collectif donc qu'est-ce que
cette collectivité là et cette
collectivité leurs dépens des faits qui
appartiennent à cette nation le don dans
certains cas parce que le jeu comme je
les dis quand qu'on prouve le tir faut
prouver une occupation d'aujourd'hui à
la date de ce très souvent la date de
souveraineté dépenses la date de loi sur
les indiens qui est fixé à 1875 premier
voisin alors lorsqu'on veut devant le
tribunal
pour prouver un titre qu'est-ce qu'on
fait lorsqu'on arrive à la distance en
15 qu'il faut continuer leur voyage dans
le temps plus ya pas de voix suis à dire
y'a pas de conseil demande est ce c'est
là qu'il faut prouver déterminer quelle
était la structure de gouvernance avant
la création du conseil devant vous allez
voir que dans la jurisprudence puis dans
les recherches historiques
dans certains cas la gouvernance c'est
simplement fusionner puis une harmonie
d'une transition qui aujourd'hui est le
conseil de banque dans ce cas là même
s'il conseille de vendre c'est juste la
loi c indique la réserve
ils ont eu une amap gassian de la
gouvernance traditionnelle en sorte
qu'aujourd'hui elle est détenue par ce
même chef et conseil devant donc pas de
problèmes légitimes de nos cultures
facilité alors que dans d'autres cas la
gouvernance traditionnelle s'est
maintenue en parallèle non retenu par la
loi ces indiens mais c'est néanmoins
mais ne sente dans certains cas blanche
surmotivés par les mots rock est un bon
exemple avec la langue baoulé maire de
clap toute la structure qui existe avec
leur propre constitution pirlo d'autres
dans l'ouest on parle beaucoup des
conseils des aînés chez les inuit
également des notions similaire dans
certaines nations nomades les chefs de
famille de territoire que peu de places
très influent dans gouvernance
alors il existe de façon parallèle des
sources gouvernementales il la
jurisprudence est venu reconnaître là je
la jurisprudence dans un arrêt récent
en colombie britannique est venu dit on
peut pas assumer qu'un conseil de bande
et le détenir 2 un titre monte on peut
pas l'assumer
on peut pas non plus le résumé parce que
peut-être que la collectivité représenté
par autre chose conservant donc c'est
pas autorisé qu'il faudrait pas se
lancer dans une cause devant les
tribunaux en prenant pour acquis que le
conseil de vendre et le détenir que le
détenteur collectif de tirs au but 17
buts les choses et ça complique mario ça
doit d'une façon du nom il faut aller au
tribunal il faut le prouver
peut-être l'exercice doit être fait
d'une façon on dit non et c'est à chacun
de la fin alors on parlait tout à
l'heure canada etats unis c'est là qu'on
va se rendre avec elisha on va parler
d'un forage qui a lieu dans la région du
refuge faunique de l'arctique c'est où
exactement si tu es nous le lieu sûr
ceci donne l'extrême arctique de
l'alaska
et puis c'est très contreversé ça
revienne dans la nouvelle beaucoup ces
temps ci
et puis juste pour pour les spectateurs
qui entend de ça pour la première fois
c'est en 2017 que le congrès américain a
voté pour ouvrir cette réfugiée aux
explorations
oui et puis cette année maintenant avec
la paralysie à washington
tout est un peu au ralenti mais le
gouvernement américaine prévoit de voeux
et m comment ces deux m'étais permis
d'exploration cette année se sait ce
qu'il veut avant il faut faire les
essais sismiques et puis la nation gucci
et nationaux autochtone qui achève la
frontière canadienne et américaine
ça fait longtemps qu est ce par contre
tout à fait rage dans cette région leurs
mais les questions transnationales et
ceux qui ça complique les choses
la ressource la préoccupation principale
je dirais c'est le troupeau des caribous
porcupine qui traverse qui mixe entre le
canada et les états unis
et c'est absolument clé pour la
subsistance de la nation woodson et
aussi les énigmes et en alaska et au
canada alors c'est une combats qui
durent depuis longtemps mais maintenant
avec le vote en 2017 et puis les
intentions pour 2019
ça revient dans une nouvelle
beaucoup ces temps-ci énormément oui
alors là qu'est ce qui va se passer en
fait comment les la nation les communes
autant américain que canadiens comment
est ce qu'ils se tiennent ensemble
comment est ce qu ils tous les patients
c'est l'écouté très intéressant parce
que depuis 1900 la faim dans les années
80 les greens du côté américain et
canadien sont mis ensemble pour
commencer un comité pour travailler
source ensemble et puis audi pour nous
on n'était jamais dit qu'on est d'accord
que la rue simonds l'alaska aux états
unis on se voit comme une nation où les
problèmes qu'on aborde ensemble oui et
mais ce qui est intéressant j'ai parlé
récemment avec le chef dan hurts de rem
je sais pas si vous les connaissez
et puis lui ai dit avec lui on a parlé
beaucoup de lait les problèmes au canada
aujourd'hui mais il dit que dans ce
dossier la levure kitchen nation et
digérées sans beaucoup d'appuis du le
gouvernement fédéral et les
gouvernements les au keno et puis au uk
aussi c'est le chef devenu wee cc lui à
la droite
et puis lui ai dit c'est comme peut-être
un exemple de comment les coopérations
politique c'est peut-être une modèle
pour d'autres régions du canada est une
chose vous avez dit ça tout à l'heure ce
qu'il dit il faut pas toujours ils
pensent qu'au canada il ya un débat qui
doivent être faits pour des comores
avait jumelé la connaissance et nous et
nous et les premiers nation ou une
huître au 6 mai avec les meilleures
pratiques de le savoir occidentaux et
faire ça ensemble parce qu'il dit
beaucoup de communautés comme le sienne
il veut le développement économique et
les emplois pour l'époque mais avec les
projections de ni n'infirmant aussi je
sais pas si vous avez travaillé sur le
dossier
on a travaillé sur des dossiers
similaires est évidemment un défi inter
juridictionnelle dans ce projet là parce
qu'il ya une portion canadienne une
porte américains puis étrangement mais
de façon non surprenante c'est pas la
même
jurisprudence et reconnaissance de
droits entre les états unis et le canada
il n'y a pas d'article 35 aux etats unis
n'est pas de droits autochtones qui sont
constitutionnaliser et il leur part
contre la jurisprudence au niveau des
ressources naturelles commence à être un
peu similaire c'est à dire récemment aux
etats-unis c'était dans l'état de
washington où est ce que le gouvernement
de l'état avait fait des travaux sur des
routes qui permette m'étais pas
seulement de remonter une rivière puis
faisant en sorte que le saumon se
rendait plus dans le territoire d'une
profanation qui avait un triptyque
s'était fait dire vous aurez toujours le
droit de pêcher les réparations coûtait
2 milliards de dollars pour mettre des
structures nécessaires que le poisson
peut se monter mais la cour suprême de
cet état leur venue dit vous devez
respecter le traité
vous devez faire ces travaux là parce
que vous avez donnée aux autochtones ce
droit de pêcher oui alors vous voyez que
même aux états unis où est ce que la
question des droits autochtones
après la révolution comme priaulx comme
diminuer au fil du temps il commence à
voir une abondance de jurisprudence qui
vient remettre la priorité des droits
tout en fait il ya sept une certaine
harmonie on peut dire des rentrées jeudi
son fonds en sorte que des projets inter
frontalier comme ça pourrait avoir une
reconnaissance conjointe au niveau de ce
que les gens veulent surtout lorsque les
ressources travers cette france que ce
soit le cas hibou le poisson les autres
espèces l'offre pour protéger une région
complet mais ça va nécessiter un
encadrement également entre les deux
états mais ce rien n'empêche menaçante
octobre de sas et de s'allier et de
prendre incertaine
une certaines juridictions d'un
territoire parce que vous savez l'auto
niveau mental une des questions c'est
dire ok il ya les réserves indiennes que
le territoire ancestral sur les réserves
indiennes bon il ya des compétences qui
sont donnés par la loi sur les indiens
pire d'autres programmes
on peut ouvrir des garderies on peut
avoir de la police sortent de chez eux
qu'ils m'aiment et lorsqu'on sembla
réserve la juridiction devient beaucoup
plus complexe est une des choses qui est
recommandé la sphère des premières
nations s'est faite votre propre
planification de vos tables de vos
ressources naturelles même s'il part
reconnu par l'état fait là parce qu'à un
moment donné si elle est bien faite et
qu'elle peut venir sans cadrer ou se
fusionner que la planification de l'état
au niveau des espèces de haut niveau de
l'environnement
mais il peut y avoir cette espèce de
cogestion où est ce que je demande la
notion du savoir traditionnel avec la
science peut venir s'harmoniser puis
donner des résultats quand même assez
intéressant puis si on garde au québec
c'est de plus en plus que la nation
enquirer avec la convention n'avait
agent depuis qu'elle a signé une entente
agrément lorsqu'avec sur une certaine un
gouvernement régional paritaire
attendant le dr mais il se lance dans
cette planification commune du
territoire des ressources qui pourraient
donner des résultats assez intéressant
bon vous touchez la question aux
québécois c'est fort intéressant et la
question décrit parce que on a
l'impression jusqu'à maintenant en
termes d'antan globale que la seule
entendre que le gouvernement du québec a
réussi à signer c'est avec les cris ont
négocié avec des attikameks vous le
savez depuis
des années 80 j'étais assez serré on
négociait déjà avec le fameux conseil
arctique avec mon temps avant que ça
implose
qu'est ce qui bloque comment ça se fait
que le gouvernement du québec est
incapable de s'entendre avec daisy nous
avec les attikameks sur une entente
globale justement où le territoire est
au centre des enjeux
parce que la réponse est assez simple en
quelque sorte
elle est très complète mère est
également est assez simple c'est que
dans si je prends pas un exemple avant
de vous parler de soi sont par exemple
attikameks et hino sais que mes temps
d'un territoire nord-ouest
voici qu a pas de population et aux
municipalités aux apports des clés ligne
et quand les clichois ont signé leur
traité au début des années 2000
byers eu quarante mille kilomètres
carrés de pleine propriété de terres
sauf à cela tous aux droits miniers ou
est-ce que l'ayant retenu 1 25% de
propriété sur l'est sur les premiers en
quelles sont mes quarante mille
kilomètres carrés sénat mais ils sont
propriétaires de toits parce qu'il n'y
avait pas d'intérêt incompatible
chez les et nous mise à part quelques
exceptions et chez ati québec on pense
qu'on est au milieu de nulle part mais
c'est tout l'été les trois structures et
des municipalités des caf d'edéa
programmant forestier déclin minier des
zecs des pourvoiries un droit exclusif
des chalets quand vous regardez sur une
carte puis vous juxtaposez l'ensemble
des intérêts non autochtones là dessus
il ya plus de place pour le grand maman
ne peut pas se compromettre parce qu' il
faudrait à ce moment là qui exproprie
des droits et intérêts de tiers qui ont
été à la banque emprunté 50 milles pour
se construire un chalet puis ils veulent
pas se faire dire non challenge
l'appareil ya trop de monde impliqué
sérieux maintenant trop de gens c'est
que les toits puis on en est étonné
parce qu'on se dit voyons on est en
région il ya quelques villages comment
ça se fait il ya énormément l'intérêt
énormément de territoire secret on a
voulu démocratiser l'état de la couronne
ce qui a été réussi au québec mais en
compte 7 au détriment des peuples
autochtones et malheureusement il n'y a
pas de solution facile
autrement que d'harmoniser cette
cohabitation nécessaire et c'est ça qui
prend du temps parce que l'autochtone
zabeth pourquoi je dois reconnaître
cette compagnie forestière là qui fait
de la coupe à blanc surmonté les toits
pourquoi je dois reconnaître qu autour
d'un lac
il ya 40 chalets on m'enlève l'accès au
grand mére umaga et lilou est ce que
j'ai encore un territoire où ce que j'ai
encore une ligne de tram alors cesser
ces questions au jour le jour
concrètement dans le gouvernement de hun
bord de la personne de l'autre et c'est
ça qui se négocie c'est là par l'acq
région par région chemin parchemin et
c'est excessivement long qu'on doit
trouver des solutions perdait la nation
autochtone se dit ben ma seule option
c'est de leur corps parce que je n'ai
pas donné mon consentement que j'ai pas
été consulté sur tout ce je dois prendre
ça comme un fait acquis il y en est pas
question
alors certains considèrent notre combi
britanniques de plus en plus de se
tourner vers le tribunal pour faire
reconnaître leurs titres plutôt que de
contrats négociés dans des conditions et
c'est la raison pour le rapport de
forces est plus ou moins fort les
papillons on parlait la convention de la
baie james
il ya un autre il ya un autre traité qui
a été avantageux dans les 26 c'est celui
des innue du labrador et le le point
corrélation entre la convention dans les
jeunes et les aînés de la ballon c'est
des mégaprojets les inuit sont tombés
dans le timing de vos six baies le
gouvernement terre meuble absolument une
entente jodie que ce que vous vivez dans
votre été en échange de l'accord de vos
six baies silhouettes ont donné bien en
vue le retraité encore là l'importance
des assises territoriales quand on
négocie et l'importance du timing d'un
grand projet à l'aide parce que s'il y
avait eu un projet gigantesque pour les
jeunes ou les attikameks il aurait
obtenu une convention de la baie james
mais aussi quand un rapport de force
ou est-ce que tu le mets en comparaison
un projet qui devrait créer des milliers
d'emplois puis des revenus et non pour
les gouvernements mais le gouvernement
sort sa calculette et je peux pas
risquer de perdre ce projet là qu'est ce
que ça va prendre pour que je l'obtiens
mais en l'absence d'un rapport de force
on se retrouve confronté à cette
cohabitation que je viens d'expliquer ni
plus ni moins et le rapport de force
autochtone à ce moment là est assez fun
alors des confrontations nous aurons
sûrement l'occasion d'en parler au cours
des prochains mois parce que il risque
d'y en avoir il ya plusieurs grands
dossiers qui sont ouverts actuellement
aujourd'hui on a mis la table on va vous
réinviter parce que vous connaissez bien
votre matière ont dû vevo par apple a au
cours des dernières minutes
merci maître andré d'être venu mon
peuple a parlé de ces dossiers là merci
guy mois on voit que vous si vous
maîtrisez bien ce dossier le népotisme
et merci hellich encore une fois de nous
avoir parlé d' un exemple très concret
c'était l'exemple concret du jour merci
beaucoup merci merci et merci à vous
bien sûr d'avoir encore une fois
participé à ce facebook live d'ici
espace autochtone en direct nous
travaillons sur le sujet de la semaine
prochaine et vous le saurez la semaine
prochaine au revoir
[Musique]